next week Las Vegas plays host to the
top female Executives for the Stevie
Awards celebrating women entrepreneurs
in business and a new study finds Nevada
makes the top 10 list for entrepreneurs
a look now at advice for starting a
business or improving an existing one
entrepreneurs are grappling with an
unprecedented shift in how and where
Americans work live and spend some
states have become hot spots for
businesses like Nevada which comes in
ninth as the best state for
entrepreneurs according to the
Harrington Group International rankings
determined by analyzing taxes jobs the
startup survival rate and consumer
spending from 2020 to the present time
when I was starting out as an
entrepreneur Dr Kaplan Mulholland is the
founder of ifinance she took her company
from startup to more than two billion
dollars in loan applications her most
valuable lesson learned think Big Show
investors you believe in your business
plan and too many entrepreneurs make the
mistake of thinking a little bit
differently they think small they think
about their friends their family what
they're familiar with think globally
think big think Mass distribution Define
that business model early on do a market
analysis Find Out Who Your competitors
are if you want to be an attractive
borrower when applying for alone think
of how the banker or lender thinks if
they're meeting with you they want to
loan you money so go into that business
meeting when you're looking for funds of
what they want from you and how they can
make money from you give them that
Comfort level that they're going to get
a return on their investment
Dr Ann Kaplan Mulholland is a finalist
this year for women of the year she'll
be in town next Wednesday through Friday
celebrating women in business for the
Stevie Awards